hey drew it's leo aka chili tumble king  and i'm here to show you how to make my  favorite smoothie bowl the drew berry  marble  first add one cup of frozen fruit to  your blender second add two slightly  thought acai packets to the blender oh  it's looking good third add a quarter  cup of any milk you choose  then blend on high until it's super  duper smooth  now that you've blended the base pour in  a bowl and smooth out the top oh that  looks good now it's time to garnish you  can use almost anything to garnish  granola hazelnut spread or maybe even  fruits but since this is the drew  barrymore bowl i'm gonna use some of her  favorite color yellow to add some banana  and some other things and then obviously  some berries for the drew barry marshall  look at the final product it could be in  the museum and it tastes great too mwah